I've been sitting here for nearly a minute without entertainment.
Change the battery in the remote.
The one on the left.
The one on the left?
Well, that's just spooky.
Not really.
I have the knack.
The knack?
For technology.
My mom says I always have.
I'm worried about little Dilbert.
He's not like other kids.
What do you mean?
Yesterday, I left him alone for a minute and he disassembled the TV, our clock and the stereo.
That's perfectly normal.
Kids take things apart.
The part that worries me is he used the components to build a ham radio set.
Oh dear.
Is that bad?
Normally, I'd want to run an EEG on him but the machine isn't working.
It's worse than I feared.
What is it?
I'm afraid your son has the knack.
The knack?
The knack.
It's a rare condition characterized by an extreme intuition...
...about all things mechanical and electrical.
And utter social ineptitude.
Can he lead a normal life?
No.
He'll be an engineer.
There, there.
Don't blame yourself.
Will it go away over time?
It might.
But pray it doesn't.
If an engineer loses the knack, the results can be devastating.
Thanks for filling in for our regular doctor on such short notice.
I was in the neighborhood.